what is up guys I'm David Ahmadi here
with John Luke and we've had a chance to
play destiny to shadow keep but there's
this new free-to-play version of destiny
too called new light and since destiny 2
is not free-to-play it brings this
really interesting question of how has
new light fundamentally changed the
structure of destiny 2 now John Luke you
got to play through new light you made a
brand new character on a completely new
account so why don't you noted my
expansions and all right no expansions
at all so why don't you tell me how has
destiny changed like how hasn't you let
changed how's that different it's really
interesting because the if you play
destiny at launch up until like now that
game was very much tied to its story you
were locked out of like the tower you
didn't get until you beat that campaign
things like strikes and and crucible
like you kind of had to play through the
story to slowly unlock that stuff new
light throws all that out the window and
just wants to give you all of that right
away so the beginning of new light for
new players has you go through the
cosmodrome which is sort of like a
redone version of the intro to destiny 1
it's basically the exact same mission
the ghost dialogue is slightly different
it's also actually been like visually
reworked it's really nice looking nice
but it's pretty much just there as like
a alternate intro to and personally I
think it's a better intro for new
players because I think it's a it's a
better way to introduce you to the world
where destiny 2's intro which I like is
very much the continuing like adventures
of destiny so after that it it just
throws you right into the tower like
immediately and it kind of sort of
treats it like you are a guardian that
is in the current now timeline of
destiny right and from then on you can
technically do whatever you want but the
game does give you a series of intro
quests to kind of introduce you the new
player to destiny so it makes you go to
Banshee and you get a new gun and then
it explains like hey that new gun has a
higher light level here's how light
levels work and stuff like that that
introduction
you know exactly it's a lot of text
reading for sure I don't know if that's
necessarily the most ideal tutorial but
it feels like they're making an effort
to like explain these concepts in a way
it makes you go talk to
of allah which is really funny actually
because he gives you this funny
exposition dump where he's just like
hello new guardian that is the traveler
over there he's who gives us our
immortality this is the last city we our
guardian the traveler is better than and
as mysterious as ever but it remains the
source of our immortality exactly like I
it's needed especially for a new plane
you have no idea what's up with
Destiny's lore I just thought it was
kind of funny cuz it's like they clearly
wrote this to be like an exposition
right totally but yeah like he
introduces you to like it's funny like
out of the gate they're like they make
you talk to this of Allah first and then
they're like hey here go do a strike and
they just ask you to do a strike right
away or you want ya they throw you one
like right away if you want to go do it
you don't have to but you can and in my
experience I'm pretty sure it always
gives you arms-dealer okay which is a
good intro strike it's it's got good
like witty dialogue and it's pretty
funny one
totally and also I think it tries to
matchmake you with other new players so
I don't know if this was pure
coincidence or not but when I played it
I was also playing with people who were
clearly brand new just started
free-to-play character and they were all
each a different class as me so I have
one of each I had one of each and I was
like was this on purpose or is it the
coincidence I don't know but it was
pretty cool is around this is a nice
intro and and they kind of throw you
right into like give you a taste before
they they kind of like keep tutorial
izing it for you and then from there
it's like they teach you about like okay
hey you did that strike that was pretty
cool now there's bounties and and and
kind of explaining so it seems like
they're slowly trying to piece it
together they have you talked about
Korra and stuff like that however there
are some weird things where for example
they don't explain who ADA from the
black mark the black armory is at all
they don't explain like you can go and
talk to her and there's no intro
cutscene anymore it's just like weird
here's here she is
here's her bounties you can't do them
yet because you don't have the forges
unlocked by here she is yeah so she's
just there and I'm curious if because I
didn't you know at a certain point I was
like okay I've played enough I'm gonna
go actually play shadow keifa so I don't
know if maybe eventually it introduces
that to you
or if maybe you get that intro cutscene
if you own forsaken cuz I specifically
tested I do not have any expansions at
all right because I want to see what
that was like but yeah you don't get an
intro for her you don't get an intro for
The Drifter or for Benedict okay so that
was kind of weird around like alright
what's up with these guys like I don't
know but otherwise it very much is
trying to sort of seed you throughout
the structure of Destiny's campaign
without actually having the campaign so
it says hey you should go down to earth
to the e DZ and you should go talk to
devran and he basically runs you through
that adventure where you do the lost
sector like he's it's the same stuff
from that campaign like exactly but they
just kind of put it right away and don't
have any of those campaign missions
right because they just want like
they're teaching you all these mechanics
the other thing is that all the other
destinations are actually locked
you only have earth available at the
start okay
so even though gotcha so you should be
able to unlock all destinations it's
just not right up from the get-go no so
instead when you go into the map it
actually says once you reach a certain
XP cap it'll unlock the destinations and
so and it does in the order so it's like
first don't like Titan then you all
unlock messes and then you know I think
that's pretty smart because it's meant
to not overwhelm you right so the one
exception is that if you own an
expansion it will actually immediately
unlock it so for example if you own
shadow keep the moon will automatically
be unlocked gotcha and if you own first
sake and it will automatically unlock
the tangle to shore and you can go do
those because you start at 750 right if
you're worried like you have to go grind
a little bit before you could like play
shadow keep with your friends if you're
like hopping and brand new you if you
don't shadow keep you you get out you're
fine you can ask you can jump in yeah
you can just jump in I think they the
unlocking thing with the other planets
is just to try an easy win and not
overwhelm you from the start which is
fair yeah so I think it's pretty good
this is like a good way to to introduce
people to to destiny it feels like
they're trying to not overwhelm players
but then I was thinking like wait a
minute how does the actual red war
campaign work that yeah how do you
activate because that was so core to
that experience so you
to go talk to Amanda holiday okay and
it's under this thing called legacy
content and it has the red war campaign
and then it has Osiris and war mine they
are really treating those three like
story campaigns as like they said legacy
content it's not mandatory anymore it's
not part of like the the path they I
think it's there for players who want to
experience it and watch it's more
content right but I think they are like
kind of tucking away because it's like
that will confuse players and we are new
players and we don't we rather them just
like get right in and play with their
friends new stuff right right which is
so that's really interesting if you
start the red war campaign it just pops
up like an icon on the tower map and
then it just goes right into like the
beginning of destiny to the destiny to
vanilla campaign yeah exactly on fire
towers on fire you're doing all that
it's actually really weird it plays the
same like tutorial ization that that
mission did we're like it's like hey hit
you know see the crouch and all this
stuff which I just did right for the
Cosmodrome mission some letter repeated
tutorial yeah I'm like that's kind of
weird but yeah otherwise it is like the
exact same thing like after you do that
mission you get taken to the farm it's
the farm and no one's there because it's
the farm right right even though in like
vanilla was like that was where everyone
was where everyone was right and so it's
like it takes you to the farm and then
it has you go to the shard to get your
your light back right it's weird because
as a new character you start with all
three classes unlocked with all of the
abilities already unlocked wow you you
just have everything in your powers
unlock from the get-go with the
exception of the third subclass the
third subclass stuff that you get from
Forsaken or shadow key right on those
four that when you do that like traveler
mission I was where you go to the shard
I was curious like am i smoking on my
power like how does that work brother
they temporarily lock off your power for
that mission once you get your like
shard power back you just get all three
classes back okay it's like kind of
weird right yeah it's like a little
janky feels a little arbitrary maybe
realize oh dang I'm pretty sure it was
like story quests where you go back to
the shard to get your other two
subclasses right or like gone I don't
think those are in the game anymore
because you just have those classes at
the start
so you like they were like chopping some
of like the fat off yes like this isn't
necessary like we don't need this to be
in here anymore which is probably best
for new players a little sad I kind of
like those missions cuz the characters
would be like reading essentially the
grimoire cards from destiny wine that's
right yeah the Lord like Dolores stuff I
thought was cool but yeah as far as like
introducing new players like not just
give them all the classes at the start
like they don't need that right it yeah
like you can basically just like do the
red war campaign and it'll follow you
through that whole structure but at any
point you can just leave and go back to
the tower and just get all your powers
back and just get all your powers back
and like at any point you're just like
I'm back in the tower and all that stuff
is there oh another interesting thing is
that I was saying how the destinations
are locked until you reach a certain XP
right so if you do the red war campaign
it will unlock those destinations that
way as well the way it did in the
original game like you'd hit a story
point you'd say hey is the ball is on
Titan go to Titan now so when I did it
I still had half of my XP like bar left
to fill before Titan would unlock but
because I got to that point in the red
war campaign it just automatically
unlocked Titan for me because that was
the next point in the story so that
isn't you can still do that that path if
you want if you were like hey I still
want to play destiny TVs original
campaign as a new player you can do that
and you can follow that path and it'll
unlock stuff for that way but you just
don't have to do that anymore that's
nice you know it kind of gives me
players the option to so mmm that's a
that's a good thing for sure
yeah it's really interesting I mean I
was just gonna bring up because it seems
like what you mentioned in your
experience with new light would you
consider that this experience the way
that they kind of repackage things to be
friendly to new players yeah so I mean I
just want to kind of get your thoughts
on it like is the material economy
different for people who aren't paying
for the game like do they do they have
kind of like a chip on their shoulder do
they have to pay more for material
exchanges you know is it is it friendly
right I mean that's that's something I
didn't really think about until one of
our co-workers brought it up because
there are games that totally do that
where it's like you're a freebie players
they've got to pay more for this and
then the premium
they're over here with their nice stuff
but outside of like the the new season
past stuff or like if you own it you get
that like the premium trap premium trap
outside of that there's nothing
different about like the way the economy
works like you are just essentially in
destiny so like ever vers prices aren't
different if you're free to play or
anything like that and you're not you're
you're not really locked off from that
much outside of like the big like story
campaigns stuff or like Forsaken and
shadow key you have access to everything
in like gambit and everything in the
crucible and right almost you know a ton
of the strikes it's a pretty sizable
amount to play like even though they're
clearly kind of putting the red war
campaign to the side if you choose to do
it in my opinion that's still like a
pretty decent first-person shooter
campaign that'll probably look good you
know five to seven hours and it's like
hey that's a good thing to do right
right so I think there's a lot there for
beginner players I also think like as a
veteran player I prefer this new path
because when you wanted to make a new
character as a veteran player you had to
replay that campaign right like to go
through that whole structure yeah now
it's like no I make a new character and
I do that like quick little Cosmodrome
intro and then it's like cool I'm 750 I
got all my stuff and I can just I can
just do what I want to do with this
character and not really like worry
about like going through that whole
campaign you just dive right in yeah
yeah it's it's really fascinating how
they've had to kind of like rip out the
guts of this because like destiny 2 was
structured so specifically around that
campaign it's like completely different
now and it really makes me think that
the eventual destiny 3 whenever that
comes out will probably be structure
from the get-go around a more
free-to-play set up of introducing
players right now like and probably
won't be structured the way destiny 2
was originally structured at lunch cuz
it really wasn't
it worked at the time but like now they
needed to change it cuz it was just like
hey you want to get into destiny like
yeah I really do like all right cool
go play the campaign I'll see you in 10
hours yeah and then we can play like
and maybe not even that because maybe
there was a light level difference maybe
there was like gear restrictions maybe I
was you know or in the case of a lack of
cross eight maybe your friend was on a
completely different platform like yeah
for sure so there does seem to be a lot
of like a like a total overhaul with new
light that I like it
I know I think it's good I think it's
better for front for new players and I
think it's even like I said it's better
for veterans to who want to make another
character I mean it's not perfect like I
at the end of the day there's always
gonna be weird quirks with trying to
introduce a new player especially goes
destiny so story heavy and it like
layers so for example like Cades just
never in the tower like as a new player
you'll never have that experience of
Kade being in the tower being a part of
that story and then having feels like
even those little treasure chests yeah
yeah like the kids lost cash isn't right
like that's not a thing right like yeah
there are things that are just gone now
and like experiences you'll never have
as a new player as a veteran player I'm
like oh man like it's kind of a bummer
you don't get to have like that
emotional experience but it's there's
not really ever a good solution for that
kind of stuff to run out it's like I
don't know how you would fix that like I
considering like what they had to work
with and that they are kind of like
jerry-rigging destiny to be structured
differently I think they did a really
good job for sure so we've been playing
a lot of shadow keep and we're
definitely gonna be covering it a lot
more so if there's anything interesting
that you guys are very curious about or
things that you want to know more about
definitely let us know in the comments
and we'll be covering it in the near
future thanks for watching guys thank
you